this is canada's capital city the heart
of its financial district the seat of
its government overtaken for a third
consecutive weekend
there are festival vibes but not for
many local people who oppose these
demonstrations
a state of emergency has been declared
in ontario the province which includes
ottawa these protesters have been warned
that if they don't go home they face
fines of up to 100 000
or even prison time
but police are outnumbered here and
lorries are still being refueled to keep
engines idling is it something that's
dividing people 100
um my neighbors on either side of me
basically told me they hate me and hope
i die alone
um
because you want the money because it's
my fault because i'm not vaccinated what
do you believe that this movement is
about so i feel like it started with the
movement of the truckers um you know
protesting mandates for them to go
across to the states and i feel like it
turned into quite a bigger movement of
people fighting against mandating the
vaccine i don't think there's anything
that could make me leave
we're here for the long haul
maxine bernier leader of the far-right
people's party of canada is a popular
man here the first week of this protest
there were people in the crowd with with
nazi flags is there a racist fringe to
this movement
you have to ask
no it is not like you can see one guy
was there with a
configuration flag is it far right
movement this it is it is not it's
people that are fighting to regain their
freedoms that's it
[Applause]
[Music]
eight hours away on the border of the
usa and canada police did move in to
shut down this protest a vital trade
route between the two countries had been
shut for five days but in the built-up
area of downtown ottawa where thousands
have converged the resolve here seems to
be growing